make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and we're getting back into dawn of X
and I know it's been a little while
since we covered Donna Beck's stuff
honestly like with Swan and everything
and with moving and all that kind of
stuff it's kind of become a little bit
of a it became a little bit chaotic for
a while but I'm finally in here I think
I'm gonna do a live stream where I'm
like painting my office doing things
like that just kind of way to interact
and talk with you guys but but we're
getting into really kind of finishing up
the first volume of New Mutants now this
was a little weird this first volume
quote-unquote runs about nine issues
whereas most traditional volumes run
about six and the reason why is because
you've actually kind of got two stories
being told here at the same time now for
those of you guys who are looking to
catch up on anything you'll find my
playlists to the x-men down in the
description there's all kinds of videos
they are about like characters like
Nightcrawler Road Magneto all those
characters explained different things
like that kind of giving you their
backstories publication histories to
make you an expert on them and then in
addition to that we have house and
powers of X and what we did is we kind
of went through and kind of prune the
playlist right it's one of the things
we've talked about to sort of bear with
me here for a second but we essentially
prune to the playlist and so far that if
it was not referenced by Jonathan
Hickman in house and powers of X we
didn't put it in there and the reason
why was just because of the fact that at
that point you know there's so much
that's happened in the x-men's history
but we kind of have to rely on what it
is that Marvel's doing in this this
really kind of still ongoing reboot um
in order to decide what needs to say in
what doesn't right so that playlist
would change all the time the meat and
potatoes of this is that up to this
point really with the the first group of
New Mutants with Sun fire and and magic
and all these characters they'd
essentially gone into space for no other
reason and to rescue Sam Gosling right
because Sam was one of the original new
mutants and the idea was to get the
original team back together again right
so that was the whole gist behind it
what they ended up kind of running into
were some some issues with the
starjammers and so on and so forth and
what it did is it landed them here but
they have to s4 death quite and we'll
talk about her here in a second the
other part of the story dealt with the
the efforts of armor to basically go and
grab beat who was really more of a newer
member of the New Mutants who had
essentially gone missing before the
events of the formation of Kirk OA and
like kind of the safe haven for the
mutant population so we really actually
kind of pick up with with gladiator
himself now one thing to bear in mind
here is that gladiator has kind of been
the magistrate or the leader of the
Shiar empire for quite some time and
really since the defeat of vulcan right
to kind of follow this timeline a little
bit when the Shiar in
haier was first introduced in Marvel
Comics the leader at the time was a guy
named akin and the can was really on the
hunt for the m'kraan crystal that was
really a big part of the Phoenix and the
Dark Phoenix saga is really the Phoenix
saga more than anything else but
following the defeat of de Ken his
sister Lalande Renier Imani took his
place and she was the longest-running
leader of the Shiar Empire in male
comics until the events of x-men deadly
Genesis the introduction of Vulcan the
third Sommers brother the omega-level
mutant that went into like war of kings
and that kind of a thing but once he was
defeated then gladiator in turn took his
place and so a gladiator was the leader
of the Shiar empire during like Jonathan
Hitman's Avengers and New Avengers and
all that kind of stuff during the era of
the x-men essentially running everything
after the wharf Kings right so from 2010
to about 2015 16 or so it was it was
gladiator and even up until about this
point and the reason why that's changed
is because gladiator is no longer the
leader of this year instead it's
essentially the daughter of lilandra now
what this does is it leads to him
essentially tasking Oracle or really
kind of asking the question you know how
far are we are we on the mission of like
you know basically getting a death bird
back here because death bird was
previously in exile and she's gonna play
kind of a big role here but Oracle
herself who's really sort of this
psychic that I was always kind of worked
as like the right hand of the Oracle
ends up meeting with this super
clandestine group now the death
commandos as they're introduced here or
essentially Marvel's version of The
Suicide Squad right in the sense that in
DC Comics the Suicide Squad is a team
it's basically sitting in for black ops
missions and they're they're expendable
right if one of them dies somebody else
takes their place and there's really no
mourning them or having a very big huge
military funeral or anything like that
it's just the nature of the business
with the death commandos these are a
wholly new introduction by Jonathan
Hickman and it's actually a cool idea
and the reason why is because the death
commandos are basically one of these
groups that are intentionally designed
to go on suicide missions their leader
is black cloak and black cloak is really
the only instance where that role always
stays the same the person that plays
black cloak may change but it's always a
black cloak that leads the death
commandos now these are guys who are
basically tasked with achieving their
mission by any means necessary so it's
almost kind of like you know here in the
real world where like you have the CIA
right in the CIA is the intelligence
gathering apparatus of the United States
focusing on everything outside of the US
where the FBI focuses on everything
inside the States but the CIA also has
involvement with some
seedy groups that are out there that
cannot officially exist you know if
they're ever caught then they basically
be disavowed and the government would
you know deny any knowledge of their
existence that kind of a thing
that's how this works with the death
commandos but basically if they're being
tasked with taking out death burden so
essentially Oracle's working directly
against the Shiar Empire here so it's
kind of a big deal because when that
happens and essentially when the New
Mutants finally catch up with death bird
immediately sunspot is in love he's just
kind of like yeah you know Robert
DaCosta is all about this girl now one
thing to understand about Robert DeCosta
is he was always you know well not
really always I mean in more recent
years it's kind of its kind of waxed and
waned right and the more recent stories
with like Avengers and New Avengers he
was kind of like the hardcore guy when
you got into like all new new mutants
more or less you know when you when he
essentially was kind of leading his own
team you know he was really kind of the
Joker and that that theme has kind of
remained since but in a lot of ways he
and Sam Guthrie were kind of the one-two
punch of the comedic relief and just the
fun guys right they were just fun to
read about it's one of the things that
made them so popular over the years but
like he's immediately smitten for this
girl by death Burt is of course the
woman that tried to like usurp the
throne of the Shiar Empire multiple
times so she's kind of a dick but uh but
nonetheless as soon as they arrive the
death commandos immediately begin their
process of saying like okay let's start
seeding on these guys right let's let's
basically take their ship out and let's
try to eliminate them now as they stow
aboard the ship what the end of finding
out is they bit off more than they can
chew now here's the important thing to
understand in the Shiar Empire you have
the Imperial Guard and then you have the
death commandos because the death
commandos are considered to be cannon
fodder and because they can't nobody can
really acknowledge that they exist
they're not composed of the most
powerful beings out there right if they
were the equivalent of the annihilates
right you had like Silver Surfer and you
had beta ray bill and you had Drax a
destroyer a gladiator if you had a team
that was composed of like this
powerhouse of individuals well the whole
universe would know about their
existence right so if the easiest way to
kind of keep them under the radar it
should just basically compose a team of
cannon fodder and that's essentially it
now it doesn't mean they're useless but
what it does mean is that we couldn't
look at them and expect them to be
capable of taking on any of the x-men
related teams and that's exactly what
happens here right for the most part
once they still aboard this ship that
various members of the team are taken
out quite readily by the new mutants
there's not a whole lot of struggle
going on here right I mean it's just
using their various abilities and
overpowering the team like that if this
was the Imperial Guard this fight would
have been over before
began right the New Mutants would have
been absolutely decimated they never
would have stood a chance because the
Imperial Guard is the show of force from
the Shiar empire right like they're it's
like their versions of The Avengers
you know alike and so as a result of
that the death commandos end up
basically detonating the ship above the
New Mutants presumably leaving everybody
for dead now what this does is this
picks back up with Edie Britain's
portion of the New Mutants and this is
where the second part of the story kind
of comes into play right you have New
Mutants on earth and then you've got New
Mutants in space this part of the story
we're gonna kind of ham through pretty
quickly not a whole lot doing here it's
basically just kind of a retcon insofar
as you had Veeck who is out there he had
his wife and they were kind of living
their own lives and ultimately ended up
settling up with beaks parents because
of the fact that beach parents are
basically dying and it was kind of
trying to spend those last few moments
together and that's why he never showed
up on katoa when you ended up having
like the kind of consolidation of the
mutant population now what you also had
with Manon and his sister who had the
ability to manipulate the emotional
state of other people and so kind of
initiating a bit of a fight going on
here you ended up having like kind of
the leader of the of the gang the guy
was kind of like hey like we're looking
for medicines from kokoa you're gonna go
there you're gonna get him for it you're
gonna bring him back this guy really
kind of brings him to sharp relief the
idea that he's really kind of working
for hard to help and specifically for
the government really kind of seems to
be the case the government's trying to
find ways to attain the various
medicines of kokoa because of their
abilities to enhance the lives of other
people
now this is really designed to kind of
hit at the notion that like it's not
really just some governments and
organizations out there that are like
key be mutants contained and not
allowing mutants to leave using them as
like a labor force different things like
that but there are government's out
there who are going by neo to extreme
lengths even so far as like kidnapping
mutants in order to ransom medicines out
of cacoa for the survival of those
mutants for their lives and it kind of
makes sense because kirko is so
protective of their mutant population
and wouldn't really open wouldn't risk
open warfare with governments right you
know it'd be easy for the x-men to just
send in a strike team and then just like
annihilate you know all those soldiers
and then take the x-men back but it
would be considered an act of war on
humanity and so of course that would
lead into a full-scale war between the
mutant population and humans and as
we've seen over the years and Marvel
Comics that war only ever really goes in
one of two extremes either it leads to
the total destruction of the x-men would
and really the mutant population which
is what Jonathan Hickman was really
hitting out with the house and powers
are back stories or if we if you guys
remember that story where you had
magneto who basically destroyed you know
all life on earth it leads to the to the
mutant population annihilating all of
humanity right so we can kind of go
either way here but the long and short
of this is that ultimately in the kind
of huge break out of fire fighting and
so on and so forth and and you know this
earth-based team of new mutants trying
to rescue beacon his wife and their kids
and so on and so forth that beak is
injured and beaks parents are both
killed and so in response to that this
leader of this new kind of fealty more
or less this main bad guy you know ends
up basically saying like Ben he's more
or less a failure here right his task
was to gather you know medicines from
Tekoa by ransoming off the the members
of the New Mutants but because of the
fact that he's failed the cartel would
kill him and then of course it would
reflect poorly on the government and so
on and so his statement is more people
will come after you right like more
folks are gonna come after you and the
guy basically awesome self right is it's
a super quick into the end of the whole
thing but the big retcon here kind of
comes in the play when you end up having
Maxine and man and who basically used
their powers to essentially wipe the
mind of beat his wife and their kids of
beats parents having died the way they
did instead they're replaced with
memories of beach parents having died
sometime ago of old age and that's
essentially yet the big takeaway here
and it only really matters if you're a
fan of the character of Beek and his
wife is that essentially you can kind of
go forward now in Marvel Comics with the
whole history that he had thereof like
his parents and so on and so forth all
being removed right so it's basically
beat the way he was at the beginning of
his introduction in Marvel Comics it's
not really important unless you're a fan
of that character it may come back to
Roose and Ed Britain is really kind of
leaving some some threads for future
plot lines to come into play here but
again we can kind of pass through that
pretty quickly and the reason why is
because the biggest kind of brunt of
what's going on here is really with with
what's happening with this new mutant
team in space now again what we're gonna
see when we get into the x-men comics is
that once you know everything kind of
gets sorted out that they're really
gonna seem to kind of blend in that
everything is gonna sort of go back to
the to the status quo of them being
there and the new mutant comic looks
like it will actually focus on what ed
worsen is doing here but again what
cross that bridge once we get to it but
the long and short is that with the the
various new mutants being taken captive
by the by the death commandos and more
or less kind of being tortured being
knocked out that kind of a thing that
the day's ultimately saved by decosta
and really by desperate when she takes
out a couple of these guys you know
black cloak and so on now this is
important and the reason why this is
important is it's really the way that
Jonathan Hickman does it for a
of people out there who are new when it
comes to the x-men they don't really
know much about the Shiar they don't
really know much about death bird or
lilandra or gladiator ernia that stuff
and it's really kind of foreign to them
and over the years deaf bird had kind of
been depicted as this sort of political
saboteur in the sense that she was
always vying for the throne and would
take it by any means that she could but
the reality is that deaf bird is a
prodigious fighter she is exceedingly
good in hand-to-hand combat not the
absolute best in Marvel Comics why she's
no taskmaster what she is really really
good and being able to hold her own
against other people having a kind of
ruthlessness having a murderous streak
really sort of amplifies that and makes
her more exemplary in her ability to
fight we all no holds barred and so
because of that she's able to take these
guys out pretty quickly and essentially
rescue the rest of the New Mutants and
then you kind of get this moment where
you know where she kind of kisses Robert
Acosta so it really kind of seems to be
of a blit of a bit of a blooming romance
there the important thing to understand
his deathbed will do whatever she needs
to do in order to achieve her gold even
if it means leading Robert DeCosta on
right and he's buying into it like full
on and so what this does is it basically
leads you to this kind of conversation
I don't really a huge conversation of
sorts but the arrival of the New Mutants
really into into Shiar space right
finally showing up on the doorstep of of
gladiator in the Shiar Empire and when
that happens of course death Bert
arriving here ah you know one of the one
of the things she does that you know
kind of talking to the daughter of
lilandra is she says like my life has
being brought here is to basically be
your tutor to be your instructor now
there's a couple reasons why this is
being done it's being done one because
what it does is it gives Jonathan
Hickman the ability to show us who-who
death bird is right to kind of give us
an indication of her character what
she's about to sort of show us and kind
of give new readers the ropes on what
kind of a person she is the other part
of this is it's better to have the devil
on there on your right hand than to be
in their path and that's true here right
with death bird she's always looking to
take the throne as it was better to have
her in a position to where you can kind
of keep an eye on earth than to just
have her out there in space somewhere
and not really knowing what it is if
she's planned but there's also kind of
an honor bound thing here right really
has her nice death Birds kind of
honorbound not in really any kind of
agreement that was struck but just
because of the fact that the new ruler
is again basically blood now deaf bird
will probably try to take the throne
that's probably going to try to happen
it's just the nature of her character
but what she says is
my job as your instructor here is to
basically teach you what it means to be
a warrior is to teach you the history
and the nature of of the Shiar empire
and your first lesson is that there's no
mercy for traders and she immediately
basically throws a spear at Oracle with
the intention to kill her and of course
gladiator catches it in turn but what it
does is it leads to an all-out fight
between the two right now this is kind
of interesting here and it's almost kind
of like a mini Phoenix saga story right
in the sense that in the original
Phoenix saga in order to determine
whether or not Jean Grey as the Phoenix
would live or die the x-men had to fight
the Imperial Guard and they lost right
it was just kind of a display of how
powerful the Imperial Guard was but it's
kind of this this quick little moment
here the reality is that as you see this
unfold for the most part the new mutants
are kind of able to hold their own if
I'm being honest with you guys it
shouldn't really be that way but what
you are talking about are some different
kinds of powers right it'd be different
if the new mutants had the exact same
powers as the original x-men and then
like they were able to hold their own it
wouldn't really make a whole lot of
sense here but you've got sunspot who's
able to channel solar energy in a way
that the other x-men weren't really able
to do you've got Sam Guthrie who can
basically just kind of you know fly at
people more or less but you've got some
you got a different kind of display of
powers here
Wolfsbane shouldn't really be here I
mean it's you know wools Bane's okay
Rayne Sinclair's okay she's just like a
really ferocious fighter they can make
herself into a wolf that's basically it
magic is really the one that kind of has
the ability to turn the tide she's very
very overpowered but before we really
get too far into this the daughter of
lilandra basically tells everybody to
stop and says explain what's going on
here and the response of gladiator is
really kind of the responses it always
is really kind of solidifying his role
that gladiator as the leader of the APO
Guard serves the throne of the Shiar
Empire it doesn't matter who's on that
throne his job is to protect the Shiar
Empire and to protect the throne and in
this instance from his perspective a
death bird is back to her old tricks
again by trying to sub you know take out
members of the Shiar and secure a place
on the throne and so on and so forth
what death bird ends up revealing here
is that Oracle tried to have death bird
killed that Oracle was actively working
against the wishes of what was best for
the Shiar Empire now the reality is that
where Princess Sandra is kind of here as
the new ruler of the throne and well and
death Bert was being brought here in
order to serve as a kind of aid to
Xandra what this means is that that
Oracle was working against the Empress
and doing that is an act of heresy right
it's an act of treason of the highest
order
punishable by death and so when when
Glenn
asks is this true the response of orful
is yes that is absolutely meant to be
true that gladiator as far as Oracle is
concerned is the one who is meant to
rule and there's a kind of validity
there in in terms of her argument the
reason why is because gladiator is a
warrior right that's what he is he's not
a politician he doesn't care about
politics he's a warrior he'll do
politics because he had to when he was
the magistrate so he was the Magister
when he was a leader of the Shiar Empire
but it wasn't really his bread and
butter he undertook the throne because
somebody needed to and as an honorable
man oracle found a kind of solace in
that right something that hadn't really
been found for quite some time that with
lalande russia did kind of have a strong
streak but the reality was she couldn't
really maintain her own position right
she relied on other people around her to
maintain her position as the empress
which is technically kind of the role
right that's why you had the Imperial
Guard that's why you have a royal
bodyguard that's why you have people
like Oracle and so on and so forth but
with gladiator if somebody came running
up on and wanting to challenge the
throne he could hold his own in that
fight right as a strontium his powers
change based on his based on his
confidence and if his confidence is
booming he is an absolute demon right
it's just ridiculous how powerful he is
and so as a result of that really is
kind of one of these things were at the
end of the day a gladiator says you know
I appreciate your candor but you've
worked against the throne the punishment
for this is death and that's basically
where Xandra steps in the daughter of
lilandra and says no we're not going to
do that instead you are going to serve
as basically my advisor you're going to
serve as my right hand that's going to
be your punishment and the reason why
this is kind of a punishment here is
because it's considered to be
dishonorable because now Oracle
basically owes a life debt to to
princess Sandra meaning if she betrays
that then she will die and there'll be
no version she won't be exiled or
anything like that
she'll be eliminated right so they kind
of be humiliated and embarrassed and
then made to serve as an advisor as
opposed to a member of Her Royal Guard
is a huge downgrade right so things are
kind of a struggle there and so what
this does is of course it leads to the
to the New Mutants arriving back on
earth with a day more or less having
been saved but the biggest takeaway from
all this and this is really kind of the
reasons why Jonathan Hickman seems to
have crafted this story is one Sam
Guthrie chooses to stay behind right so
basically the whole mission was for
nothing
the whole mission was for naught but
then you end up learning that Robert
Acosta actually bought one of the
apartment complexes on the Shiar
homeworld in order to be closer to death
bird because again he's kind of smitten
with her and so him and Sam Guthrie are
gonna kind of be hanging out so
basically some spots gonna be staying
behind it looks like staying on on on
Chandalar but the other big thing that
kind of comes out of this is cyclops
begins having a conversation with
gladiator now keep in mind while they
don't really relate all that often
they're well aware of who the other hits
and that was one of the big things that
came out of Chris Claremont Phoenix saga
is that where the x-men did lose to the
Imperial Guard the Imperial Guard
developed a huge amount of respect for
the x-men because of what they were
fighting for because of the of the
strength and bigger they were fighting
with and because of what they believed
because of their efforts on earth
there's a kind of honor there's a kind
of respect that comes with that right by
kind of respect among warriors it's
really what this is this is one of the
reasons why during John I'm sorry during
a Chris Claremont's x-men Cyclops became
so prominent right became such a huge
character is because he was just kind of
like the boy scout more or less
understand Lee and Jack Kirby it wasn't
until you got to Claremont that it was
like dude there's some meat and potatoes
to this guy right like there's some
there's some cool build up here that's
what kind of lead into the House of M
era and and really kind of like the fall
of Cyclops and why it was so intriguing
and so cool is because you were
following this you know 60 years story
of this character watching him grow and
expand and kind of change over the years
and different things like that it was
exceedingly well done but what Cyclops
requests of a gladiator is to basically
have one of the one of the Kirk Owen
gates installed on Chandalar that's a
big thing because what it does is it
grants the x-men instant access to the
Shiar empire they can walk through a
gate on cacoa and come through a gate
there now this is also a huge moment
because what it does is it basically
solidifies the notion that the gates of
kirkuk or a universe wide you can reach
any point in the universe with a Kirk
Owen gate now how far it takes you to
get to a location to install a gate
there is relative to how fast you can
travel from one location to the next
right so you know using the technology
of Reed Richards and then traveling to
this location it would work for the most
part but with regards to this this
instance here this is kind of a big deal
right because what you sort of get is
Robert decosta and Sam Guthrie sort of
docked together as they're one-two punch
comedic duo which is gonna be awesome
the x-men now have a gate in on the
Shiar home world meaning they can reach
them at any point in time and the Shiar
can come to earth at any point in time
it sets things up for some
big crossovers between these characters
right between these teams which is a
pretty big deal because having that the
Imperial Guard and the x-men working
together is no small thing that's
actually really really awesome but would
that being said guys we're to go ahead
and bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explained to
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]